nos dicen sea fx igual a equis estoy
dividido entre 1 - el consell de x2 y
nos piden elegir la opción correcta para
los límites unilaterales de f en x
igualados ahora lo primero que quiero
que veas es que es lo que pasa si
nosotros evaluamos la función en x
igualados si hacemos eso efe de 2 me va
a quedar como 2 entre 1 - el coseno de 2
- 2
ahora el coseno de 2 - 2 es lo mismo que
el coste no de 0 pero uno menos 10 así
que me quedaría 2 entre 0 y puedes ver
que esta función no está definida en x
igualados y es por eso que sería
bastante interesante encontrar el límite
en cuanto x aproximados y en especial
los límites unilaterales bien intentemos
aproximarnos a esto y hay un par de
maneras en la que podrían hacerlo una de
ellas es que podrían hacer esto sin
calculadora con solo examinar lo que
sucede aquí pensando en las propiedades
de la función coseno y si esto te
inspiran pausa
e intentar resolverlo yo lo voy a
trabajar de esta manera hasta el final
del vídeo ahora bien la otra manera es
que si tienes calculadora puedes hacer
una tabla como hemos hecho en otros
problemas de ejemplo en otros vídeos y
así pensar qué es lo que va a pasar con
x cuando se aproxima a 2
este premio pensemos que es lo que pasa
con x cuando se aproxima 2 en dirección
positiva por aquí voy a tener a xy por
equipo ya tener a fx y bueno pensemos en
valores mayores que 2 no se podría ser
2.1 y 2.01 ahora la razón por la que
dije calculadora es porque estos valores
no son triviales para evaluar en esta
función sin embargo vamos a intentarlo
tengo 2.1 esto a su vez dividido entre 1
- el costello y aquí me quedaría 2.1
menos dos lo cual es 0.1
entonces el coseno de 0.1 haciendo una
calculadora yo sé que el coche no es 01
así que esto de aquí debe ser muy
cercano a 1 sin llegar a 1 y de hecho va
a ser menor que 1 porque la función
coseno nunca
ser mayor que uno recuerda la función
coseno está limitada entre menos uno y
uno déjame escribir lo menos uno es
menor o igual que el coseno dx que a su
vez es menor o igual que uno la función
coseno sololá entre estos dos valores
así que esto va a estar aproximándose a
uno pero va a ser menor que uno
definitivamente no puede ser mayor que
uno de hecho esa es una buena pista para
ver cómo pueden explorar la estructura
de esta expresión y luego podrían decir
muy bien ahora vamos con 2.01 eso va a
ser 2.0 1 entre 1 - el coseno de n bueno
aquí tengo 2.012 es 0.01 entonces me
queda el coseno de 0.01 que observa que
esto va a ser todavía más cercano a 101
pero de nuevo esto va a ser menor que 1
no importa que el coste no de cualquier
cosa va a estar entre menos uno y uno
inclusive con estos valores porque
mientras nos aproximamos a todos esta
cosa va a aproximarse a uno por debajo
por un valor menor así que ya podemos
tener un poco de intuición
esto se está aproximando a uno por
debajo entonces uno menos eso va a ser
algo positivo a medida que nos
aproximamos a dos y bueno el numerador
es positivo eso quiere decir que toda
esta expresión entera va a ser positiva
pero por otra parte va a ser un valor no
acotado en dirección positiva como
veremos esto no es acotado ya que la
segunda evaluación es a un más cercana a
una que esta primera evaluación ahora no
hace falta decir que esto no va a ser
acotado en dirección positiva eso quiere
decir que vamos a ir así infinito
positivo así que solamente estas dos
opciones tienen ese resultado y ahora
podemos hacer exactamente el mismo
argumento a medida de que nos
aproximamos a dos por la izquierda así
que vamos a hacer una tabla por aquí
tengo a x y por aquí tengo a efe de x y
una vez más no tengo calculadora
entonces ustedes podrían evaluar estas
cosas en su casa y que vean muy
claramente que son positivos a medida
que nos acercamos a este valor de 2 se
vuelven valores positivos más y más y
más grandes y lo mismo va a pasar si
tomamos por ejemplo
1.9 y si tomamos al 1.99 ya que aquí me
quedaría 1.9 entre 1 - 12 no me de aquí
tendrían 1.92 entonces esto me quedaría
como menos 0.1 movamos la pantalla
porque el segundo va a ser 1.99 entre 1
menos el coche no de menos 0.01 y el
concepto de menos 0.1 es exactamente lo
mismo que el coste de 0.1 y el coseno de
- 0.01 es lo mismo que el coseno de 0.01
entonces estas dos cosas van a ser
exactamente igual esta de aquí va a ser
igual a ésta y esta de aquí va a ser
igual a esta otra y por lo tanto nos
vamos a aproximar de nuevo a infinito
positivo así que la única opción donde
veo que todo esto es cierto es justo la
primera si nos aproximamos a dos del
lado derecho o del lado izquierdo nos
estamos aproximando en ambos casos a más
infinito ahora bien también hay otra
manera en la que podría deducir
exactamente
puedes fijarte que a medida que nos
aproximamos a 2 el numerador va a ser
positivo ya que el 2 es positivo y luego
aquí a medida que nos aproximamos a 2 el
coseno de cualquier cosa no puede ser
mayor que 1 pero además esto se va a
aproximar a 1 porque es menor que 1 así
que esto es menor que 1 a medida que x
se aproxima a dos y de hecho se vuelve
uno cuanto x es igual a 2 y luego esto
de aquí me queda uno menos o se note
algo menor que 1 lo cual va a ser
positivo en primer lugar y en segundo
lugar vamos a obtener un valor muy
pequeño cada vez que nos acerquemos más
a uno vamos a obtener un valor más
pequeño entonces al final tengo algo
positivo dividido entre algo positivo lo
cual en definitiva me va a dar un valor
positivo y por otra parte como ya vimos
sabemos que esto va a ser algo no
agotado así que de nuevo es cogeríamos
la primera opción como la correcta y va
a ser algún agotado porque observa entre
más cercanos estemos de 2 entonces este
valor va a ser más cercano a 0 y entre
más cercano estemos de 0 esto va a ser
más cercano a 1 y si esto es más cercano
a 1 entonces el denominador va a ser muy
chicos y luego si dividimos algo entre
algo muy muy muy chico eso va a volverse
poco a poco no acotado y va a tender a
infinito
así que si observas es exactamente lo
que vemos en la primera opción